[Music]
in gender neutral news submitted by
adult Ninja Turtles the old ones
Barbie creator Mattel is now releasing
gender-neutral dolls what so they look
like aliens
I guess they kind of sort of walk - the
tips for this oh [ __ ] oh oh Ellen
DeGeneres kind of yeah that's cool just
looks like a pretty yeah pretty boy yeah
yes so pretty twelve-year-old boy yeah
because they felt like um like a lot of
kids were saying they didn't relate to
like the girly girl dolls and they
wanted they knew they would get around
Christmastime they were gonna get dolls
that they don't relate to so yeah well
so what ugly like me they can express
themselves the way they want to
you could wear like a variety of
different outfits some are more male
presenting or masculine presenting some
are more feminine presenting but they
also come with like wigs and different
assortments of outfits so if one day
you're like oh I feel more tomboyish you
could do that and if like another day
you're like oh actually I want long hair
today like they have all kinds of
different options now they put on like
titties or like ass or like whatever
like I want my what a bigger ass that's
interesting to me do you think that it's
healthy and I mean it's just like a
question but like do you think that it's
healthy for your self-image to be
reactive to your mood of the day
what do you mean reactive like it's it's
like you're like sometimes people say
like oh I'm feeling tomboyish today I'm
feeling depressed I'm gonna wear all
black I'm feeling girly today yeah I
think that's healthy self-expression
because you're a child even like you
look at children like my brother used to
put on my dresses all the time
he wasn't like I'm a girl but he like
felt like he wanted to wear dress and
like fly around in a dress that day you
know and I was just like you don't stop
kids from doing that it's creative
yeah it's creative they're exploring
like what they're interested in they
don't know they are yeah there's like
today I'm a GI Joe
tomorrow I'm a ninja I literally do that
every day I got I got a question so it's
kind of like piggybacking on those
questions so that's self-expression
right do you think it's good
if the parents are kind of taking their
own perception into what they think the
kid is so maybe they find a boy with
maybe softer features and you're like oh
my son
is kind of feminine so instead of buying
him I don't know the cholo Barbie that's
all macho I'm gonna get them this one
with softer features and then maybe they
yeah maybe the kids yeah like that I
would actually love to put out like five
dolls or something like that and be like
hey which one do you want I'd be curious
to see what they do it was already at
two Tyler and he tells me when he like
he picked out his own Halloween costume
what is he like what is HECO like he
wants to be Mickey Mouse yeah but like
though that you make like Barbies is a
very feminine boy oh yeah they already
start gravitating towards things that
they like if you pay attention to your
kid like you already start picking up
like okay they like doing very like like
um I knew I liked weapons and pirates
yeah more like like I'm not gonna have
type of sit there and try to like teach
him [ __ ] reading and Shae cuz he
doesn't give a [ __ ] and I'm like I could
push that on him really really hard
that's what I want yeah what he would
rather do is play basketball or play
with an instrument so I just kind of
like just guide him in that direction
my friend liked to get his sister's
Barbie and put it in his pants
and walk around all day and so for the
whole day we would hang out with his
Bart with his sister's Barbies in our
pants and we're just for some reason we
thought it was so cool yeah that was my
son I'd get him his own Barbie and I'm
like okay ah stop doing so her dick was
all upon the Barbie yeah but maybe it's
a dominance thing where like he's like
Leon it doesn't it doesn't feel the same
if it's my Barbie like I did conquer the
other part yeah so that comes with like
just taking them to like the toy store
and letting them you can't even control
them if you wanted to you can't be like
you're getting this because you're not
gonna play it like how many times did
you get as a kid that your parents got
you there like I didn't want this [ __ ]
like traumatizing castles been because
of me going to we went to start wars
convention like Museum I obviously just
wanted to go to the souvenir shop and
get a lightsaber but my dad got me a
sticker book and I'm like I'm not gonna
play with that and play with this
exactly
said that to them that's why I got Hugh
Jass Reubens that you are grateful
because we don't know nothing about
price and money and how expensive you
know is I don't want the sticker boogies
like you get this put that back and I'm
like alright I said alright you're gonna
get it but I'm not gonna play with it
and I put this up like put this or it's
a lightsaber it's too expensive
yeah so it was like but we don't know
that as kids you don't know that how
much things cost and is assumed that you
hate me and you don't want me to be
happy yeah the only thing I'm scared of
is that parents would push this [ __ ] on
their kids I mean like they make them
gay as hell no biggie the kids get to
choose tell me more assuming what's the
kid yeah so like look it so this doll is
the same doll yeah and they get to they
get the kids get to choose like they
want to put her in a powder bag white
white belt or black no they're only
looking at one day though the same doll
like this side in this side no the one
that we she showed me earlier is not
that's a difference but I thought
there's always been different outfits
you can do different hairstyles and then
there's like gods and they stay the same
and they're white and though they're all
frou-frou dresses they're not and
they're all heels like Barbie has like
feels no thick Barbie's you can buy the
thicker Barbie there's all diverse
Barbies but what about obese Barbie what
about those people
I don't know that didn't do very well I
remember watching the Barbie documentary
I want to see there's more plastic in
the Barbie maybe they're actually they
made these in there hoping that to spark
some dialogue around what dolls are for
and who dolls are for I like that
because I would hate like I've always
hated that like the girls section has
like the cleaning in the kitchen and
then the guy section has I caught my
Legos all the time I just like building
things and engineering things and like
making things work and like learning
like how things work and it would always
be like they just give me the dolls and
they give him to Legos he didn't give a
[ __ ] about the Legos he'd always still a
dolls
you know what's crazy they did a study
with babies that have like pre societal
like I guess pressures or whatever and
it is about 80 to 90% of babies though
that are girls they already gravitate
towards that it's what it is by look
part of it is biological but you guys
are like that
did you cheat me enjoy exactly to be
able to choose like I'm sure 80% would
choose the kitchen set or whatever but I
was pissed that I didn't get to choose
because yeah all I wanted to do is build
Legos and no one would ever give me
Legos for Christmas and they'd always
give it to him have girl Legos now they
have girl Legos which is like why is
that to be girly
still building it easy bake oven set
that's 10 because I was like that's
[ __ ] don't have to be blank we
shouldn't have to be well ours yeah well
I didn't care the but if it was a girly
thing or not I just wanted the cupcake
in the things inside and in like the two
favorite things that I would do is like
play guns with my friend we shoot each
other and after that we play house hmm
so then like we're like they were like
cooking later and then like someone's a
dog and someone's the sister and [ __ ]
start shooting each other again and I'm
like that was my favorite too kind of
things and people that had like those
what do you call it like those
playhouses i think that was the dopest
[ __ ] ever tree houses play houses all
she don't differentiate between this is
a boy thing and a girl thing i think
kids are like that I like this I like
weird oh yeah anything you could cook
little mini stove I was like man it's
tight I recently bought Tyco like this
cleaning said it comes out like a mop a
broom and she always watches like me or
his grandma cleaning and he's always
trying to do it with that shop all the
time yes like here you go here's your so
he's like dusting I'm like I can't wait
to have a kid
I'm dude like I'm stall ready very
because I'm like like it's so corny but
I imagine like me plus the person that I
love making a thing that's both of us
and then we get to love it yeah and it's
gonna let me back I hope it does yeah I
think you're like the coolest person
ever so they're like eight or dead yeah
yeah yeah and then you're embarrassing I
didn't have any brothers or sisters so
the concept of something that kind of
looks like me and
like you know like that's so exciting
and like it's like I'm gonna be like
like not anytime soon
I can wait but I'm ready you're like
you've always talked about like waiting
on it and then you know you're like I
need it when I'm 33 knocked me up what's
the what's the public saying idea about
it are they like most a lot of people
are really they're into at least the
conversation about it they knew that
some parents weren't gonna like it but
they're like we're not here to tell you
how to you know raise your child you can
still buy the regular Barbies you don't
have to you don't have to do it this way
yeah it's just an option they said oh
yeah Mattel president Richard Dickson
acknowledged not all parents would be
comfortable with buying the
gender-inclusive dolls for their
children commenting we respect the
decision any parent makes around how
they raised their kids but hopefully the
creation of dolls were served to educate
adults further about the inclusive world
their children are growing up in yeah
and I think this is really dope cuz like
um like when I was growing up like I
wasn't around a lot of like when I was a
little little I wasn't around any other
ethnicity other than Mexican so then
when I saw my first Asian person I was
like what the [ __ ] is that what kind of
[ __ ] aliens I'm like this looks like
nothing I've ever seen before how old I
was really young like before preschool
maybe at preschool this is the world we
live in
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]